E
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THAN PROBABLY
OTHER THINGS ON CAPITOL HILL
THIS YEAR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO HOW BIG A THREAT IS CHINA TO
BUSINESS, CULTURE, AND THE WORLD
IN TERMS OF UNLEASHING ANOTHER
PANDEMIC?
WHY WOULD PRESLEY TRY TO
MINIMIZE THAT WHEN IT'S SUCH A
BIG PROBLEM?
>> FOR HER BEING WOKE IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN BEING ALIVE.
IF SHE WAS PRESIDENT, WE COULD
ONLY GET TOUGH WITH WHITE
COUNTRIES.
RUSSIA, THE FRENCH, WHO I'M KIND
OF ITCHING FOR A FIGHT WITH.
IF YOU'RE JAPAN, IF YOU'RE
CHINA, IF YOU'RE THE CARTELS, IF
YOU'RE A MUSLIM NATION, YOU KNOW
WHAT, BRING IT ON.
WE'RE GOING TO LAY DOWN, BECAUSE
WE DON'T WANT TO OFFEND IN
ADDITION.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT ATTITUDE
DURING THE WAR ON TERROR?
DON'T WANT TO GET TOO TOUGH WITH
THE MUSLIMS, BECAUSE OF ISLAMA
PHOBIA.
THAT'S THE REAL THREAT.
TAKE AWAY EVERYTHING.
JUST AS YOU SAID, COVID ALONE,
THEY UNLEASHED THIS DISEASE THAT
MURDERS A MILLION AMERICANS, AND
YOU'RE SITTING IN CONGRESS,
YOU'RE, LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT, I'D
RATHER TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO HER
CONSTITUENTS ARE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THEY SUPPORT
THAT.
HER CONSTITUENTS DIED FROM
COVID-19.
THEIR FAMILIES MIGHT WANT TO GET
TOUGH ON CHINA.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN AMERICA THAT
WAS INVOLVED IN THAT LAB.
SO, YOU KNOW, SHE'S AMERICA
HATER, ANOTHER REASON TO LOOK
INTO IT.
>> YEAH.
THERE'S SO MANY QUESTIONS.
CHINA OBVIOUSLY HAS A 50-YEAR
STRATEGY FOR ACHIEVING GLOBAL
HEDGEMONEY.
THE UNITED STATES, WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT STRATEGY BASED ON
WHO'S PRESIDENT.
THE MESSAGE IN CONGRESS, WE WANT
TO PROTECT OURSELVES AS A
NATION.
WE WANT TO HAVE A POLICY ABOUT
CHINA THAT IS NOT NECESSARILY
PARTISAN.
>> I THINK THAT WHILE I AM
GENERALLY SPEAKING SYMPATHETIC
TO THE SQUAD, I LIKE AOC A LOT,
I LIKE HER VERVE, HER GRIT, HER
ENERGY, THE PROBLEM IS THAT THEY
GET OFF ON THESE TANGENTS THAT
ARE SO SILLY TO WORRY ABOUT
PEOPLE BEING ANTI-CHINA BECAUSE
OF, YOU KNOW, THESE ACTIONS THAT
THEY'RE TAKING IS RIDICULOUS,
WHEN YOU THINK CHINA IS THE
MENACE, FAR MORE THREATENING TO
THE UNITED STATES.
RUSSIA IS UNDER 200 MILLION.
CHINA IS HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS.
CHINA WILL REPRESENT OUR FUTURE
ADVERSARY FOREVER UNTIL
SOMETHING AWFUL HAPPENS.
SHRINK IT DOWN TO ANTI-ASIAN
SENTIMENT IN THE CITY AND OTHER
PLACES, WITH MANY ASIAN FRIENDS,
I CAN TELL YOU, PARTICULARLY THE
WOMEN, ARE PETRIFIED.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, A NOTORIOUS
CASE BRINGS IT TO THE FORE, BUT
THEY LIVE IN A CONSTANT SENSE
THAT THEY ARE DIFFERENT, WILL BE
SINGLED OUT, THAT EVERY PERSON
OF COLOR THAT THEY WALK PAST
THEM, THAT IS A POTENTIAL THREAT
TO THEM, IT'S REALLY VERY, VERY
SAD WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
I THINK THAT WOKENESS DOESN'T
HELP.
WHAT SHOULD -- WHAT THE APPROACH
SHOULD BE IS FRANKNESS,
CONFRONTED, REAL INCLUSION, NOT
BS, YOU KNOW, PR STUFF LIKE
THIS.
>> I WONDER WHAT HER POSITION IS
ON THE SUPREME COURT CASE IN
REGARD TO THE ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS SAYING THEY'VE BEEN
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST.
MAYBE THE MOST DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST GROUP IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
YOU KNOW, ARGUABLY THE DATA
BEARS THAT OUT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE THAT'S NOT
EVEN BEI